Qua thật hiện công tất bảo rọng đọc mạnh ninh chật tự tại Cô Sở
ngày 12 năm, năm 2019, phòng Anh Nguyễn Hộ Đi ở Công thì lọc Cái
vũ hợp với công an 3 mừng lại, tổ chức gặp gỡ tuyên chuyển
vẫn động bà hát TT, xin năm 2019, rủ tại thương Trung Tâm 3 mừng lại
tình lọc Cái, có hạt động liên quan đến pháp luôn công.
Tại bổi làm việc cơ quan công an đã tuyên chuyển các quyền định của khóc lợp.
Dạy thiết, nhiều gió bản chất phương thước hoạt động của pháp luôn công
Cũng như những tất động tiêu cực, hề lựa có thể anh hưởng đến bản thân ra đình
và tình anh đi chật tự, sau khi được tình chuyển bà hát TT đã từng người
giáo nục năm 2019 tại liệu và thầm, có nội dùng liên quan đến pháp luôn công
lôn sách tại liệu ín, thế ngành và mọi số và thầm phù vô tin nhau, cập lượt
đồng thời tương người anh vết cảm kết, không tiếp tục thăm ra các hoạt động liên quan đến pháp luôn công
không chia sẻ, tuyên chuyển, lời kéo người khác thăm ra có hạt động của pháp luôn công.
Phó vừa việc nâu trên nữ lượng công man khuyến cáo người dân, cần năng cao kính ra, chất chẳng thông tiên chuyển
lời kéo thăm ra các tổ chất nhóm sinh mặt tự phát không đúng quy địa có pháp lượt
cả trên không ra mạng và ngại xa hội không tiếp nhận niêu dữ phát hản tại liệu chơi được các quan chất năng kiểm trứng
khi phát hiện các trường hợp có rời hợp tiên chuyển lời kéo thăm ra có hành động trái quy địa
cần kịp thời thăm bà cho chính quyền đefương, hoặc các quan công man nơi gần nhất